it turns out that one of the biggest
culprits of
a lackluster complexion is stress
i feel like everything goes back to that
word stress
and these days honestly who isn't
stressed out
so today we're revealing how stress
can mess with your skin and how you can
start to fix
it starting right now okay so here
to help us is renowned dermatologist
i actually am lucky enough to go to her
she is my hero
because she's also a psychiatrist so we
are talking about
a lot of different things that come
together
with great purpose with her and she is
just everything she's here it's dr amy
wexler
thank you i mean
dr wexler i always talk about
how beauty for me really is
an inside job and i don't care what you
look like on the outside
if you are stressed if you are toxic
inside if you are miserable
if you are angry all of these things
come out
and a smile is better than any lipstick
you're ever gonna buy
period you are really connecting
something
that i think is so inextricably linked
thank you they are because the mind the
brain and the skin are formed from the
same layer of cells
so they have all these interconnections
and it works in both ways
and so when we're stressed you can see
it on our skin there's a
stress hormone called cortisol not a
it's not a good molecule because it does
a lot of bad things to the skin
increases inflammation which can cause
acne also breaks down collagen so when
someone says i just got this wrinkle
they're you know really stressed out and
it could aid you pretty quickly
it also causes the skin's barrier
function not to work as well to make our
skin more sensitive
so it causes a lot of bad things but if
you can break the stress cycle you can
undo all of that
okay that is great and we have some vfs
here with their questions
and crystal is here with her first
question hi crystal
crystal hello thank you for having me
for as long as i can remember i've
struggled with dry skin
patches on my neck my legs my arms
basically
everywhere and with kovid i've been
super super stressed i've literally
tried everything
what can i do so the stress piece the
problem is
when we're stressed out the skin's
barrier doesn't work as well it gets
leaky and leaks water and so our skin
gets more dry
so you should try to do things during
the day i don't know what your work
schedule is like to get off of zoom and
get outside for example because
getting outside in nature and getting a
little vitamin g for green really lowers
cortisol levels there's other ways to do
that too
and then there's a good skin solution
which is safflower oil
i know that sounds silly the skin makes
a natural
moisturizer called linoleic acid and
when our skin's too dry it makes less of
it
so there are two oils that are linoleic
acid
rich olive oil but if you put that in
your skin you'll smell like a salad
and safflower oil which is odorless
essentially colorless and you can get it
at any supermarket for
under ten dollars and you just take a
little bit let's try it
and rub it on your skin after your
shower when the skin acts kind of like a
sponge to soak it in
and you'll be amazed at what it does
crystal uh what do you
think of this and also i'm going to send
you a bunch of safflower
oil after the show of course
um from me and dr amy i've never used
that
safflower oil but i'm looking forward to
trying for sure
i just used a little and my two hands
are completely alive
and i am not worried about getting other
things greasy this is amazing
good thank you crystal thank you by the
way
i would like to circle back with you and
ask you how that's going okay
oh totally thank you i appreciate it
thank you ladies see you
soon okay next let's talk about
breakouts because so many people have
been complaining about mask knee
i think it's um you're on mute and i
have mask knee
are the two quotes of the last year
cycle
it really is and you're on mute is cute
and funny
um the masculine is not why are we all
going through this
new thing that wasn't there before
i'm glad you asked me that because
everyone is just assuming the masks are
causing acne
but why are we wearing masks because
we're in the middle of a pandemic and
everyone is stressed out i don't think
the mask itself is causing acne i think
it's the stress
there hasn't been a study showing oh
masks cause acne
at all you know when i used to work in
the hospital we wore mass in the or all
the time
no one ever complained about breaking
out under their mask never so what do we
do
first of all just know that this is an
issue right just
to be more mindful and figure out okay
maybe i'm extremely stressed right now
look at your sleep patterns
look at ways that you can lower your
stress level that's one and that's free
right just to take some time think about
yourself and be mindful then there are a
bunch of over-the-counter solutions for
acne
salicylic acid is great as a wash or a
spot treatment benzoyl peroxide is good
as a wash so there's lots of things to
try
some people try too many things though
and get irritated so i say two
over-the-counter products maximum
okay so we'll have all these listed on
our website okay finally adina is here
with her skin question hi adina how are
you
hi i'm good how are you i like your
flower
thank you it's summer right it is um
adina what's your question for dr amy
well this past year my skin has been
really sensitive i'm sitting on zoom all
the time i can see the red blotchiness
and it's it's just not i'm not happy
with how my skin looks
what can i do i get it dina i also have
sensitive skin
drew also and you have to be really
careful
products you use on your skin should be
fragrance free and hypoallergenic
if you're trying a new product i say do
a test spot like for three nights in a
row right in front of your ear
because then if you have a little rash
that's okay but your whole face isn't
reacting
i've always loved tea and i actually
created a
cream for sensitive skin with chanel
that has silver needle white tea in it
which has the highest concentration of
antioxidants
really soothing for the skin i also love
to drink tea it lowers cortisol levels
and relaxes you so we have some
silver needle white tea here and it's
it's really awesome
to put on your skin and to drink i don't
know why
that everybody who is in skin is not
also in the mental game because
my goodness they're just so hand in hand
anyway i'm just so glad that
you came here and i hope this is the
first of many because we are all looking
for a solution pun intended we really
are
and tips and tricks like this can be
real game changers
to our mental space because we can clear
up problems so thank you dr
amy you're welcome thank you i know i
call you all the time when i have a
problem
okay here and here make sure to check
out dr amy's amazing podcast that she
hosts with her own daughter
zoe am i embarrassing you my daughters
olive and frankie who you know um they
would say yes
yes too though she's older now so i
embarrass her less which is lovely
oh that's good and i'm always telling my
daughters i live to embarrass you
you